Following my ZRT test, and I think this person is talking about methylated estrogens.
She says to help me methylate my tooth, that's a two-hydroxyesterolds, better, she wants
to try phosphatidylcholine, B6, and 400 milligrams, B2 riboflavin, do you see any objections or
concerns with that?
I noticed the store's body bio has soy lessethin, is that important, whether it's not organic
soy?
So this, I believe, is organic soy, and this is almost every phosphatidylcholine is going
to be from soy.
Phosphatidylcholine, what is phosphatidylcholine?
Phosphatidylcholine is the building block of all your cells.
So I have no trouble with you taking this, is phosphatidylcholine, a contraindicated for
people with cancer, no, not at all?
All your cell membranes are built with phosphatidylcholine, and so is all your brain cells, so it's
good for that as well.
So no, I don't have a problem with this, I would say yes to that, go with that protocol,
and see if we get that down, or get your two-hydroxyesterolds.